the x-men franchise has weathered plenty
of ups and downs over the years with the
now iconic series playing host to its
fair share of garbage
as well as some of the greatest
superhero movies ever made here's every
one of them
ranked from worst to best in march 2019
disney finalized his acquisition of
fox's film assets and just like that
charles xavier's school for gifted
youngsters was taken over by the house
of mouse so when dark phoenix hit
theaters a few months later it was to be
the final mainline x-men movie of the
fox era
and the last film of a franchise dating
back to the year 2000
and boy did it end with a whimper dark
phoenix tells the story of jean grey
a powerful mutant who's possessed by
another worldly and all-consuming entity
this cosmic force turns gene into an
uncontrollable force of nature
who decides it's time for the x-men to
become extinct and yeah the movie itself
works about as well as that joke from
its lackluster emotional cues to his
disappointing action scenes the movie is
just a total bore
sure you could argue that one other
x-men movie is technically worse but at
least that particular misstep was good
for a laugh here you just end up
disappointed
what could have been a grand space opera
filled with thrilling space action
turned out to be a dull and
disappointing farewell to the uncanny
x-men
x-men origins wolverine was fox's return
to the x-men franchise
after the original trilogy ended in 2006
but while it's always great watching
hugh jackman have fun as wolverine even
he couldn't save this schlockfest from
heaps of cheap cgi cardboard characters
and a screenplay that doesn't even know
the difference between a wolf and a
wolverine
origins begins in the 19th century and
follows wolverine through his pre-x-men
days
including his relationship with
half-brother sabertooth his first love
and even his first dramatic yell to the
sky
unfortunately the movie is also full of
cheesy dialogue and pointless action
scenes while the obligatory romance is
so rushed that you feel practically
nothing when logan loses the love of his
life but at least there's still time for
this
adding insult to injury this is the
movie that stitched up wade wilson's
mouth giving us a dermandel version of
deadpool that kept ryan reynolds out of
the x-men universe for seven years it's
legitimately one of the worst superhero
movies ever made
after two solid entries in the series
the original x-men trilogy crashed and
burned with the last stand
set in the aftermath of jean grey's
death the last stand revolves around a
young boy who develops the ability to
cure mutants
naturally this doesn't sit well with
magneto who raises a ragtag army to kill
the kid
forcing the x-men to show up and stop
him the result is a truly messy movie
involving far too many characters
so many crucial scenes either happen
off-screen or are glossed over entirely
mystique is morphed back into a human
and then basically dropped from the plot
we never see hank mccoy grapple with his
decision regarding the mutant cure
cyclops one of the most important x-men
is even murdered off-camera
but where the last stand really falls
down is with the dark phoenix herself
remove jean grey and you lose pretty
much nothing from the film
the entire plot should have revolved
around her descent into darkness but
instead she's just there to look sexy
and make things blow up
it just doesn't work which really makes
you wonder why they decided to revisit
this mess in dark phoenix
x-men apocalypse actually has a lot
going for it the ancient egyptian intro
was pretty exciting magneto's subplot
could have been its own awesome movie
and quicksilver is as ever an absolute
delight it's just
a shame that the rest of the movie is
such a catastrophe the plot involves an
ancient deity named you guessed it
apocalypse who wants to take over the
world for
reasons and while oscar isaac
occasionally shines from under those
silly looking prosthetics
he's done no favors by a script full of
cliched dialogue and poor motivations
it doesn't help that there are too many
characters involved in the story too
from storm and psylocke to cyclops and
nightcrawler and that's not even
counting all the old characters still
around from the previous prequels
the movie is just too crowded to give
every character their due and
as a result the film falls flat during
its big emotional moments
thankfully fassbender and mcavoy bring
their scenes to life but the same can't
be said for jennifer lawrence who seems
like she really doesn't want to be there
the superhero genre was in a weird place
in the year 2000
a little over a decade before tim burton
had revitalized the genre with batman
but after a long line of flops the
genre's popularity had called and that's
when x-men came along the film was a
total hit taking superhero movies in a
new direction
and making things a little more grounded
than they had been before in short
x-men laid the groundwork for the modern
day superhero boom and whether you're a
superman fan or an avengers aficionado
you probably owe this 2000 flick a debt
of gratitude
but is it any good well you've got some
dated cgi
a laughable roar from sabertooth and two
could forget this particular low point
do you know what happens to a toad when
it's struck by lightning
nitpicks aside however brian singer's
take on the x-men is mostly fun
with characters you actually care about
simple but well choreographed action
scenes and the establishment of certain
figures who quickly became a permanent
part
of the hollywood landscape ian mckellen
is absolutely magnetic as a metal
bending magneto
for example while hugh jackman is
thrillingly feral and savage as a
wolverine all in all x-men was a
fantastic way to start the franchise and
kick off two whole decades of superhero
films
deadpool 2 is kind of like carrying a
really good dirty joke more than once
the first time it's shockingly fun but
the second time
the novelty of the r-rated edge wears
off a little directed by david leach
deadpool 2 finds a merc with a mouth
completely lost after his girlfriend
vanessa is killed but when the
indestructible trainee x-man comes
across a troubled young mutant
with a fiery temper wade wilson finds a
new purpose in his ultra-violence life
obviously there's a lot of meta-humor
going on here pretty much every comic
book property in history
is mercilessly roasted and wilson takes
aim at a near endless number of pop
culture targets too the film also
introduces some pretty cool characters
like the ever lucky domino and arguably
the greatest x-men character of all time
peter you're a goddamn superhero you
x-force
x-force after the disappointing double
whammy of the last stand and x-men
origins wolverine the x-men franchise
was in serious trouble
fortunately director matthew vaughn gave
the series a much-needed boost with
x-men first class an
origin story for the mutant super group
the crux of the movie revolves around
the contrasting world views between
charles xavier
and eric lyncher who grew up in
radically different circumstances it's
idealist versus cynic
and some of the best scenes of the movie
involve xavier and magneto discussing
their opposing perspectives on humanity
we have it in us to be the better man we
already are
we're the next stage of human evolution
you said it yourself
james mcavoy is delightful as professor
x and unlike her performance in
apocalypse jennifer lawrence is
fantastic here
portraying an earnest raven dark home
who struggles with their own self-esteem
speaking of eric lyncher michael
fassbender as magnetso might be the most
inspired bit of casting
in the franchise since hugh jackman's
wolverine fassbender's magneto is a
tragic hero grappling with the conflict
between his desire for revenge and his
need for a family
his nazi hunting scenes are powerful and
the tense standoff at the south american
bar is almost on par with a certain
other classic scene involving fassbender
beer and nazis whether he's pulling
submarines out of the ocean or yanking
metal fillings from a bad guy's mouth
fassbender more than proves his worth as
ian mckellen's successor
easily the best film in the original
trilogy x2 begins with one of the most
exciting openings in superhero history
and everything is just uphill from there
the plot follows the x-men as they
confront one of their nastiest enemies
the mutant-hating colonel striker
after he kidnaps xavier desperate the
team is forced to ally with magneto and
mystique in an effort to save the
professor
and protect mutant kind every single
character gets a moment to shine here
whether it's pyro facing off with the
cops
rogue taking down her fiery friend or
storm and nightcrawler simply discussing
their views on humanity and if you're
looking for killer action scenes
it doesn't stop at the oval office
beatdown the film's best set pieces
include striker's attack on xavier's
mansion
logan's battle with lady deathstrike and
magneto's thrilling escape from his
plastic prison
action-wise it doesn't really get much
better than this inspired by the 1982
comic series by chris claremont and
frank miller the wolverine was directed
by james mangold who later went on to
direct logan and it was the first film
to give the mutton chopped hero a
revisionist spin
this logan has lost his cocky swagger
instead he's a tired man
living as a hermit in the mountains
visited nightly by the ghost of jean
grey
all he wants out of life is death that
changes when he's invited to japan to
meet a sickly businessman he saved years
ago
afraid of dying the man wants to take
logan's powers for himself
and in exchange offers him an ordinary
life but when logan turns down the deal
he soon finds himself mysteriously
drained of his regenerative abilities
and is drawn into a plot involving a
corporate heiress shady tycoons and
yakuza thugs
drawing inspiration from everything from
the outlaw josie wales to floating
weeds james mangold crafted a truly
unique x-men movie and gave a classic
comic book hero
a whole new depth of humanity deadpool's
first appearance in x-men origins
wolverine was an
absolute disaster thankfully a few years
later wade wilson was back on the big
screen
only this time the merc with her mouth
could drop as many f-bombs as he wanted
there wasn't a stitch in sight and ryan
reynolds was able to give the craziest
performance of his career
directed by tim miller deadpool tells
the story of special up soldier turned
assassin wade wilson who is stricken
with cancer and forced to seek radical
treatment
unfortunately the cure leaves him
permanently disfigured though he does
pick up some impressive regenerative
powers in the process so after donning a
tight red suit he starts hunting the
evil scientists who destroyed his life
rude crude and kate with blood deadpool
is a wonderfully self-aware departure
from your usual superhero flick which is
probably why it's the highest grossing
r-rated film of all time
the second installment of the prequel
trilogy x-men days of future past
it's a timely why me adventure that asks
one of sci-fi's most intriguing
questions
can you change the past or is the future
set in stone the movie opens in a
devastating post-apocalypse where
mutants and nia to being wiped out by
ever-evolving androids called sentinels
these things are impossible to kill
so the x-men borrow a page from the
skynet playbook and send wolverine back
in time to stop the sentinels from ever
being created
and if x-men first class was michael
fassbender's movie then days of future
past belongs to james mcavoy this 1970s
professor x
is radically different from the wise old
museum we know and love he's angry and
depressed
beaten down by life and tortured by the
voices of the dead and dying
mcavoy gives xavier new depths
portraying him as an unkempt cynic
before transforming into a kind
and compassionate leader throw in some
crazy visuals and a few clever action
scenes and days of future past becomes a
perfect x-men film to tie the two main
eras together
directed by james mangold logan is a
sweaty dusty western
filled with lonely anti-heroes
desperately looking for hope it's set in
the year 2029 when mutants are
supposedly extinct
except for wolverine professor x and
their albino friend caliban who all live
in hiding in rural mexico
and that's when laura shows up played to
feral perfection by daphne keane
laura is both a violent animal and a
scared little girl constantly hunted
down by some seriously bad dudes after
the reluctant warrior logan steps back
into his role as hero and with xavier in
the back seat
sets off on a blood-soaked road trip to
get laura to safety hugh jackman's turn
as logan is arguably his finest
performance
not just in the franchise but in his
entire career he plays wolverine as a
tired old gunslinger
bitter lost and staring death in the
face until he's given one last shot at
redemption
patrick stewart has never been better
than professor x in his final days
either
and then of course there's that final
shot of a cross tilted into an x atop
logan's grave which might just be the
most beautiful
and heartbreaking image in x-men history
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one